そう あれさえもなんかどこかで納得いかないんですよ
だから何なのですかね
たとえスキーに行って骨が折って帰ってきても
折れて帰ってきても はっきりとこれをこういう原因でということが言えないんです
それぐらい複雑なんですよ
因果法則っていうのは
だからこの瞑想中はそんな因果法則を発見すると思ったって
もうこれをもう置いといた方がいいんです
その代わりにやるのは直接原因を探すんです
一番時間的に一番身近な原因を探すんです
それはもうすぐわかります
なぜ骨が折ったのか 前スキーに行って骨が折ったんだ
こけちゃって それでいいんです
一番近い原因 それは絶対的
それだけという意味じゃないんです
一番近い原因だから 一番力強い原因でもあります
それだけに心を絞ってほしいと
それだけやっていると必ずしももう因果法則が分かってきます
これであの ヴィパッサナーする
実践する人が単なる確認だけしていくんだけど
確認だけしていると どんどんどんどん集中力のこの倍率を上げて上げて上げて上げて確認していくと
この カンコーヒーは云々ということではなくて
その世界はなくなってしまって
ナーマとルーパだけになってしまって
例えば何か見たと 見たものはルーパで見たという自分の感覚はナーマで
そうやって分けちゃうんですね
分けたところで すごい仕事楽なんです
目に入るのは形 耳に入るのは音
舌に入るのは味 鼻に入るのは香り
だからこの複雑な限りない現象の世界はチープな一つだけに絞っちゃうんです
だから仕事はすごく少なくなる
また 複雑に残ったのは心の世界だけ
座ってあなたは何を感じますか？と言えば
ちょっと初めはわからないんです
でもどんどん観察すると
痛み 痛み 痛みとか そこで楽しみも感じる可能性あります
そこをそういう人は苦と楽と不苦不楽と 3つだけは感じます
それは受の世界 心の世界
心の受でいえば三つしかないと
で その人にはその三つ存在する
もう一人の人には苦だけですよと
苦しみだけですよと これには強弱
苦しみは柔らかい 苦しみは強いと
それだけのことで そこでなぜ痛みと認識しますかと
そちらにあってほしくない
あってほしくない感覚
あってほしくない感覚だから痛みと呼ぶんです
あってもいいやという感覚には痛みと確認しないんです
ただそれだけでしょう
だから簡単です 集中力を増していくと
それであってほしくないという場合は
そこで心の感情の世界で
そちらにはどんな煩悩
繁殖する化というと あってほしくない
逃げていけ 出ていけという気持ちだから怒りと
あ こういう感覚だったら気持ちいいんだと
今は楽しいと楽と 観察すると
それはあってもよろしいという感覚なんですね
単なる常なんです それだったら何をどんな煩悩を繁殖するかというと
欲の煩悩を繁殖する そこで痛みもでも楽でもない感覚を観察すると
別に判断しないんですね
判断できない もう感覚
他のことを感じますよと
心他のほうに行ってしまっちゃうし
そういう調子でずっといるとどうなりますかね
どんどん心が鈍くなって眠くなってしまっちゃうんですね
ということは 不苦不楽の感覚を感じる
どんな煩悩を成長します？瞋
貪瞋痴の瞋 すごいすごい
デジタル的でわかりやすいんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想進んでいくと一つ一つ
そこで怒りというものは
このラッカ ラサ パッチ
パッターナ パダッターナと 4つの立場で理解しなくちゃいけないんです
それから痛みというものもラッカ
ラサ パッチ パッターナ
パダッターナで理解しなくちゃいけない
そうやって自分にできるだけのこと全てやる必要ないんです
そのその個人にはもう何かはっきり一つのものをわかってくるでしょうし
例えば本人にとっては
例えば痛み 痛みと確認する
だからまず特色 なぜあなたは自分のことを自分に聞かなくちゃ
なぜあなたはこの感覚に痛みというんですか？それは普通の感覚よりは何か違うはずなんですね
座った 1分以内の感覚と
足を組んで座って 1分以内
2分目から痛みが生まれたりするでしょう
だから  1分前の感覚よりは 1分後の感覚
何か特色あるでしょうに
そこは自分で発見すればいいんです
私に教えてくれではなくて
それで働き どんな働きしますかと
痛みは何？どんな働きするか
楽しみはどんな働きするか
それもすごいわかりやすいですね
何か仕事してるんです
そうでないと痛みでも何でもなくなっちゃいますからね
それで自分がどのように受け取るかと
それから近い原因 一番近い原因でいいんです
やはりそこを間違うんで
時々 やはりそれを私たちは直そうとしますけど
どうしてもヴィパッサナー世界に納得してくれません
例えば 自分が小さい頃から体が弱かったんだからね
すごく足が痛くて座れませんと
あんなこと言っちゃうと
もうもう智慧が生まれてこないんですね
証拠はない 本人の妄想概念だけ
人の思考っていうのは仏教は認めませんだから
なぜかというと これ思考じゃないんだから
もうダブってダブってダブってダブっていっちゃいますからね
だからアメリカ人が日本に来て
マクドナルドさんに行って文句言うんだから
はっきりと 良くないと
私はアメリカのマクドナルド食べてもうまずいと
そういう認識は認めないんです
それは正しくないんです
ダブってるんだから そこでファストフードの例で言えば
私はもう二 三回ぐらい
この何でしたっけ 他のハンバーグ屋さんに行ってハンバーグ食べて
マクドナルドの方が全く美味しくないと決めつけちゃったんです
それははっきり自分知ってるんです
僕はこの何でしたっけ
あれはもう宣伝するお金もらってないんだから宣伝するわけにはいきませんね
モスバーガーの で ハンバーグ食べて
これはいいと判断して
その味を導入するんです
マクドナルドに ダブっておくん
置いたらまずいと そうすると好き嫌い存在するのであって
持っていかなかったならば余計なこと
好きということもないし
嫌いということでもなくなっちゃうんです
煩悩は生まれなくなっちゃうんですね
だからこれ理解しておけば
もう結構面白いんです
だから人の認識は認めないんです
だから小さな時からの体質が弱かったんだから云々という
そんなこと言っちゃうと
この直接原因が分からなくなっちゃうんです
小さい時ってどうでもいいんです
例えば 足が曲がらない人がいて曲がろうとしたんですね
で 痛みが生まれたんです
なんで痛いんですか？と
足が曲がったんだからでしょうに
それでストップしてほしいんです
足を曲がっただから痛かったと
それでそうじゃなくて
本当は私はね もうもうコレステロール高くて
なかなかこのもうアーティライティスの症候が昔からあって
それでまあこういう血圧もあって
これこれでまあ喋るは喋るは全部何の意味もない無駄話
全く仏教から見れば全く非科学的ないい加減な
そんなことでは永久的に問題に解決法はないんです
だから直接原因はもうはっきりしているんですね
足が曲がった すぐに痛かったんだから足が曲がったんだから痛かったと
それでいいんです 直接原因
そうやって痛みが生まれたらなぜ痛みかと
で その直接原因を見ると
まあそういう風に見るんですね
とにかくこの仏教では
このすべての色  二十八の色と五十二の心所と心には
この四つの定義は全部ぴったしと付いているんです
ですから それを覚えておけば
自分で発見できないというならば
まあほとんどその通りなんです
時々それにも二つ付け加えるんです
長所 短所と それで六つになります
例えば怒りなどの場合は
やっぱり長所 短所を考えた方がよろしいし
時に瞑想の慈悲喜捨の場合もよく考える
厳密に長所短所を考えるんですね
間違ったらまあどうなるか
正しくいったらどうなるかと
それで長所 短所も考えなくはならない時もありまして
別に気にしなくてもいい場合もあります
まあとにかく長所 短所
両方考えた方が立派な人間になるんで
だから物事はいいとか悪いとか何でもなくて
長所 短所 両方持ってるんだと
例えば怒る怒りには仏教では煩悩だと言って悪口言うんだけど
それでもなんで人間怒ることをやめないんですかね？何か長所あるでしょ？そうでなきゃ
だから怒ってる人々はみんな長所だけ見てる
だから怒りは収めません
それだけのこと だからどんな物事にも長所
短所 両方見た方がいいんだ
例えば宗教的になるのはありがたいんだけど
瞑想だけにもう何と言いますか
徹底的に入ってしまって
世の中見えなくなっちゃって
常識も崩れてしまって
そうするとそれ短所ばっかしでしょうに
ですから 両方考えておいた方が
いつでも中道的でうまくコントロールして正しい方向へ持っていけるんです
ですから ものひとつの現象を確認する場合は
このラッカーラサパッチュパッターナパダッターナアーディーナマアッサードアーディーナもう一つ忘れちゃった
ニッサーラナってもう一つあります
ニッサーラナっていうのは離れること
どうすればこの境界から脱出できるかと
七つですね そうするとこの定義っていうのはこの七つでするんです
そこでこの二番目のディッティビスディッっていうのは
このように人がいるわけじゃない
自分がいるわけじゃない
物体があって それは物質で
別に大したことはない
世の中の物質と体の物質も同じ
それから心の働きがある
そのからくりで痛みやら苦しみやら
もう全部その心の働きですよ
それわかってきます それから物質にしたっても
見えるもの 聞こえるものとか
まあいろいろあるんだと
あるいは自分の感覚で言えば
硬く感じるものや もう流れるように感じるもの
動くように感じる いわゆる地水火風ですね
地水火風であると四つのエネルギーを感じたりする
まあ結局体っていうのはそんなもんだと
認識だから 体は認識するんだから
自分が実際に硬さ認識する
それからぎゅっと締めることを認識する
あるいは膨らむことを認識する
それから熱を認識する
それから空間を認識するんですね
まあそれぐらい地水火風ですね
だから地水火風しか認識が実際に認識してるのは地水火風だけです
それで幻想のダブってダブってダブって組み合わせると私ですよと若いですよと年ですよとかいろいろもうくだらん概念いっぱい無意味なもの入りますけど
でも実際に感じたのはそれだけですよと
それで例えば硬さが感じちゃうと
硬さが流れていくということ
流れてるエネルギーだと感じちゃうんですね
風の幻想を感じちゃうと
あ これ動いてる動いてる幻想や
あるいは膨らませてる膨らませてる現象やと
水の幻想を感じちゃうと
粘り強く引っ張られてる引っ張られてると
それは限りなく引っ張ってもらわないと
そこで引き離す場合も
限りなくそのエネルギーが仕事をしてくれないと
ダメやということはわかるでしょうに
終わることなく だからずっと流れで
まあ質量を作るエネルギーはまあずっとそのエネルギーで働いていると
引き離すエネルギーはずっと
ずっと引き離しておかないと
だからそこはちょうどバランスをできたところで
こういう風に体のような錯覚が出てくるんだと
それについて自分が心の感覚ですか
怒りやら憎しみやら いろんなものをそこでその適当に生まれてくるんだと
そのものの流れわかってくる
心の流れわかってくる
それからこの地水火風
元素は分離してわかってくる
それで一つ一つに添いてそれなりの理解がある
硬さというのはこんな感じだと
それ何回何回も確認するともうすぐわかるんですね
これは硬い硬いと確認するもんだと
これは動いてる動いてる確認するもんだと
これは熱い熱いと感じるもんだ
確認するもんだと これは怒り
これは喜ぶと確認するもんだと
もう最も簡単に確認上手になるんで
だから確認上手になっていただければ
もうこういう問題はそんなにないんです
で そこまでいくことはディッティディスッディと言うんです
かなりの世界なんです
で 同時にどこで発見できると人が変わってるはずなんで
今まで自我があったでしょう
私がいるんだとか ああだこうだとか
私がいるということで他人と自分を区別したり
いろんなトラブルを起こしたりするでしょうに
もう私がいるわけじゃない
ナーマとルーパということに心の中でも体験していると
その分正確で見えちゃうんです
だから隠せないんです
あの瞑想成長しているかないかっていうことは
自分にも隠してない 自分も別にそういう発見してしたんだから
だからストレスはないんです
例えば 戒律の状態だったら
本当にもう貪瞋痴に引かれてるのに
不貪不瞋不痴の方に行かなくちゃいけないんだから結構きついんだけど
今は智慧の世界だから
もう納得の世界 もう納得いくと
ここでも納得いくんですね
だからディッティディスッディって言うんです
今までにあったすべての認識の世界は
これで綺麗さっぱり破れて別世界が生まれるはずなんです
今まで生きてきた評価してきた世界っていうのは
全く自分にこの真理の地水火風であろうが
ナーマルーパであろうが
それしか存在しないんだとという別世界が生まれてくる
その別世界生まれた瞬間でもう邪見はもうない
個体概念ももうない だから悟ったと錯覚する可能性はありますけどね
まだまだもう道が遠いんですけど
でもこういうところでもはっきりするんですね
やっぱり もう実体というものがないっていうこと
それでディッティディスッディというのは見清浄という言葉は使っているんです
さあ 今日でアビダンマ終了しようと思ったんだけど
全然進めなかったね じゃあもう一回で終了します